we talked about how cardi b won four
million dollars from youtuber tasha k
but here's the thing now cardi b wants
tasha k's videos removed from youtube
but at least the ones that have defamed
cardi b despite the fact that there is
now a judgment against tasha k saying
that these videos that she has uploaded
defame cardi b she has refused to take
down those videos unless ordered by a
judge which is exactly what cardi b is
trying to do here such an outcome of
removing those videos isn't automatic in
a defamation case like this but it makes
sense given that it'd be a pure victory
if you won millions of dollars from
someone that defamed you but those
videos still remained on the internet
continually defaming you and that's
generally what injunctive relief is
meant to prevent if there is an ongoing
harm that cannot be remedied by
monetary damages then the court can
issue an injunction which requires
someone to do something or refrain from
doing something and here cardi b wants
tashike to remove those videos which
allegedly continually defame her